Speaker 1: Welcome back to the
David Pakman show. I am Jesse
Dallimore sitting in for David while he is away.
Look, some stories just bring me a chef's kiss.
Amount of joy is is Chef's kiss a measurement
that I can use as how much joy I feel when I get
to talk about Donald Trump Jr and his podcast.
Donald Trump jr just started a podcast I guess
titled after his book of the same name triggered.
And in it it is similar to the videos you may
or may not see on Twitter where he gesticulate
wildly. Look, not being one who who lives in a
glass house and wants to throw stones. You know,
I'm somebody who just articulates. I'm
somebody who waves his hands around
maybe more than I should. I certainly get
taken to task on it about it on YouTube.
But Donald trump jr just has a fundamental
misunderstanding about how air quotes work
in some of these videos. He just sits there
and and does air quotes for several seconds
in a row. But everything he says.
Speaker 2: A shared desire to keep
quiet. Early on, Biden's attorneys and Justice
Department investigators both thought they had a
shared understanding about keeping the matter
quiet. But they had very different reasons.
I mean, serious when he could be leveraging
the fact that they have those secrets and
that Joe was irresponsible with them to gain
whatever advantage over the United States.
Of course, they had a desire to keep it quiet.
But the fact that the media is quiet about it,
the fact that if all the leftists
don't say anything about it,
that in and of itself is actually the story.
Speaker 1: It's just bizarre. And this is like
maybe the third episode of his podcast.
And this mashup, I believe, is from
a wrong Philip Koski on Twitter. And it really
it says a lot about what conservatives tune into
and where they get their information and what
they find credible. This is a remarkable clip,
this mash up that is as all over the place as
really anything that I've witnessed in recent
memory. It is it is schizophrenic in nature to use
colloquial lies that term. Watch this. Nuttiness
from the ex-president's son, Donald Trump Jr.
Speaker 3: This credit. It's not actually,
but the media always a discredit. They I don't
think they've been wrong on anything yet,
frankly. But, you know, the constantly said
they're discredited. That's the way the media does
the things because journalists actually refuse
to actually be journalists like, God forbid,
they do a job. God forbid they don't just rubber
stamp the Democrat talking points. And while the
company wouldn't dare admit it publicly, they
do mutate viruses, branded conspiracy theorists.
Well, like every conspiracy theorist, if you
wait a couple of weeks, you'll be proven right.
Who would possibly do that? What is this 1980s
like? Are we still pretending that all of these
people have our best intentions? Are the highly
educated and sophisticated media class that know
better that when elections, when everything's won
by basis points, margins, a couple of points here
or there, you know, those people who aren't paying
attention that much this you know what? If I can
get that guy even wondering, maybe just don't
even show up. Big part of, I think, why we're
in Ukraine. I've read some really interesting
threads about like sort of the the labs that
are over there. I'm not going to talk about them.
I got to research it a little bit more. But like,
look at why else we may be in Ukraine and why
maybe it's okay if we let other people kind
of mutate viruses. And when the Russians do
it, it's bioengineering. And when we do it,
it's checking to make sure we're preventing
can that. Yeah, yada, yada, yada. He's feeling
really unsafe right now. It really it was
they're like, well, you know, we do this,
but not really that much. I mean, what's a couple
of mutations, right? I mean, if it takes one.
Speaker 1: Doing his own research,
Donald Trump Junior, they're
talking about how every conspiracy theory, if you
wait a couple of weeks, it ends up being true.
Listen, this is hilarious and this is funny. And
it's remarkable because he's a moron. But it is
troubling because of the fact that there's a wide
swath of the country who looks at this individual,
this troubled goon, and thinks he's credible and
thinks he's smart and thinks he has it together
and thinks he has access to information that
they don't because he's the son of the X guy.
We're in trouble. I'd love to know what you
think about this. I know David has a phone
number. You can mix it up in the comments
on YouTube. This is something that I would
love to get your take on. Once again, I
am Jesse Dallimore. I host. I doubt it.
Podcast on everywhere the podcasts are.
I host the dollar more daily on YouTube
and you can catch me on social media, on
Twitter, Instagram and Tik tok I am at.